O
HEAR WHAT ISIAH HAS TO SAY,
FORGET WHAT KENNY SMITH HAS TO
SAY.
ISIAH: FIRST OF ALL, I WILL BE A
FAN AND CONGRATULATE YOU ON
GETTING TO THE FINALS.
I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT THIS
JOURNEY IS FOR US AS SMALL MAN
TRYING TO GET HERE.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF NIGHTS
WHERE I'M SURE YOU WONDERED IF
YOU WOULD EVER GET THERE, JUST
LIKE I WONDERED IF I WOULD EVER
GET THERE.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE RIGHT NOW, YOU
HAVE FOUND THE RIGHT PLACE FOR
YOU, IN TERMS OF JAMES JONES
BEING THE GENERAL MANAGER, MONTY
WILLIAMS BEING COACH, AND YOU
BEING THE COACH ON THE FLOOR.
IT FEELS LIKE THIS IS THE
PERFECT STORM AND PERFECT
SITUATION FOR YOU ARRIVING IN
THE FINALS.
THEN HAVING THE SUPPORT AND
KNOWLEDGE BASE IN THE FRONT
OFFICE THAT YOU CAN ORCHESTRATE
AND DICTATE ON THE FLOOR.
HOW DOES IT FEEL FOR YOU AS A
PLAYER?
>> IT IS A LOT OF TRUST.
I'M A FAN OF THE GAME, SO
OBVIOUSLY I WATCHED YOU ALL DAY,
EVERY DAY.
I WATCHED KENNY.
I PLAYED AGAINST SHAQ, GOT SENT
TO THE FLOOR A COUPLE OF TIMES.
SHAQ WAS A HACK.
HE USED TO JUST FOUL YOU JUST TO
LET YOU KNOW HE WAS THERE.
BUT OUR TEAM, I LOVE THE TRUST.
THE TRUST FACTOR, YOU KNOW, YOU
HAVE PLAYED IN LEAGUE WHEN
PRACTICE IS OVER, YOU SEE THE
GUY LEADING THE GYM, GAME COMES
YOU KICK IT TO HIM, IT IS LIKE
YOU DON'T WORK ON THAT.
BUT OUR TEAM, WE HAVE SUCH A
WORK TEAM.
WE CALL IT GOOD TO GREAT.
IF I HAVE A GOOD SHOT, I TRUST
THE NEXT GUY I CAN PASS IT UP
THAT WE GET A GREAT SHOT.
YOU DO IT ALL SEASON LONG, THE
COACHES DREW IT DAY IN AND DAY
OUT.
ISIAH: I'M HONORED TO BE
COMPARED AND OUR NAMES ARE
ME